- [Kim] Hi, this is Kim from Khan Academy
and today I'm learning more
about the fifth amendment
to the US Constitution.
The fifth amendment is
one of the better known
constitutional amendments
since we frequently
hear references to
suspects taking the fifth
in TV shows and movies.
But what does it actually
mean to take the fifth?
To learn more, I talk to two experts.
Donald Dripps is the Warren
Distinguished Professor of Law
at the University of
San Diego School of Law.
And Steven Saltzburg is the
Wallace and Beverly Woodbury
University Professor of Law at
George Washington Law School.
So, Professor Saltzburg
could you talk a little bit
about why the framers were
interested in choosing
to protect these rights in particular?
- [Saltzburg] The fifth
amendment really addresses
four different things.
One, it says that generally
you can't be charged
with a serious crime unless
you're indicted by a grand jury.
Two, it says you can't be
subjected to double jeopardy.
Three, it says you can't be compelled
to be a witness against yourself.
And four, there is this due process right,
not to be deprived of life, liberty,
or property without due process.
If you look at it, the three provisions,
the grand jury provision, double jeopardy,
and the privilege against
self-incrimination
all have a common history
and that is that in England
there was a time in which
the crown, the King,
basically tried to assert
power to bringing people
to trial for charges that
the King wanted brought.
And the grand jury served as a protection
between the King and ordinary people.
- [Dripps] Most of the
provisions in the Bill of Rights
are aimed at preventing the
recurrence of some specific
abuse that had been
known to English history.
There are different provisions
in the fifth amendment
that speak to different abuses.
The fundamental one and the
one that goes furthest back
in the legal history, back to Magna Carta
and so on is the due process clause.
And that clause means that
no person can be injured
by the government except
according to the law
of the land and after a fair trial.
And that in the very,
very distant past back
in the 13th century King
John had an infamous practice
of executing supposed rebellious barons
and then holding a solemn trial
after the drawing and quartering.
And so, that notion of judgment
before punishment is
really, really fundamental.
That's what due process is
about at its most basic level.
- [Kim] Interesting, so can you say more
about the due process clause here?
What is due process?
- [Saltzburg] Due process
is an extraordinarily
complicated concept.
It means that there are certain procedural
and substantive rules that must be honored
in the way in which governments
approach individuals
and entities that they
are seeking to regulate.
It's not a simple bright
line that in order
to have due process this
is what is required.
Due process is somewhat flexible.
It tends to provide more protections
when individuals are faced
with more serious consequences.
So, in terms of criminal law
it's generally understood
that the most severe
penalties that we have
that can legally be imposed upon people
are the death penalty, prison, and jail.
And generally, you can't
impose any of those except
as punishment for a crime.
And so, the due process
in the criminal arena
is largely defined by the Bill of Rights.
And some common law understandings
that have been carried forward,
let me give you a couple of examples.
There is nothing in the Constitution
that says the government must prove guilt
in a criminal case beyond
a reasonable doubt,
but that is a fundamental
part of American law.
The Supreme Court has
held that that is a part
of what due process
requires and that is the law
throughout the United
States not withstanding
the fact you don't see
it in the Constitution.
Similarly, the right to a unanimous jury
in a criminal case is
also not found anywhere
in the Constitution.
- [Kim] You mentioned a grand jury,
so how is that different
from an ordinary jury?
- [Dripps] The grand jury
served a very delicate role
in Founding era times because
many, many prosecutions
were brought by private persons.
There were no police forces
of the modern paramilitary
24/7 type and a lot of
law enforcement was done
by self help and prosecutions
were privately funded
and sometimes lay people would
represent themselves pro se
in pressing a criminal prosection.
And the grand jury was there to make sure
that people weren't
subjected to vindictive
or malicious prosecutions
by ill-spirited neighbors
and that sort of thing.
The framers probably had
in mind a famous case
of the Earl of Shaftesbury
who was suspected of misdeeds
and a grand jury famously
refused to indict him.
And so, they sought as
one among many checks
against the possible abuse of power
by this new federal government.
- [Saltzburg] So, a grand jury is a body
that decides whether or
not to bring a charge
against an individual or an
entity like a corporation.
The grand jury in federal
court happens to be 23 people,
but there isn't anything
in the constitution
that actually says it
has to be that number.
Unlike a trial by jury
which we call a petty jury,
the grand jury does not
have to be unanimous.
It basically decides to bring
a charge by majority vote
and the grand jury specifically instructed
that its job is not to
decide guilt or innocence,
its job is to decide whether
there is sufficient evidence
to bring a job.
Which we usually say means probable cause
to believe that a crime was committed
and a particular person
committed that crime.
So the grand jury's function
is to bring a charge,
the trial jury's function is to then
decide guilt or innocence.
- [Kim] Interesting, so
how about double jeopardy?
This is something that I think we have
a maybe rudimentary understanding
of in popular culture.
What does double jeopardy really mean?
- [Saltzburg] If we didn't
have a double jeopardy clause
the executive branch, if it
could persuade grand jury
to charge somebody with
a crime, could prosecute
that person and if the
person was acquitted
then government could do it again.
Bring the same change and do it again
until they got a conviction and that meant
that an individual could be persecuted
rather than prosecuted
by continuing charges
for the exact same thing.
And the basic function of
the double jeopardy clause
is to basically tell the
government, you get one shot.
- [Dripps] Trials are very
stressful and very expensive,
and the government has more resources
than the typical defendant does
and so one concern is that you would just
have the government have
power to bankrupt people
by retrying the case over and over again.
It becomes very, very
complicated saying just
what the same offense is.
The current doctrine is
that every statutory crime
that includes different factual elements
than every other statutory crime arising
out of the same course of
conduct is a separate crime.
- [Kim] Are there an
exceptions to double jeopardy,
or common misconceptions
about how it works?
- [Saltzburg] Yes, there are
two common misconceptions.
One of them is that you
can only be tried once
for the same criminal
activity and the reason
you can actually be
prosecuted more than once
is because in our system,
federal government
in each state is considered
to be a separate sovereign
which means the federal
government can charge someone
with a crime, let's say a drug conspiracy.
The State of Virginia or
California can also prosecute
for the same criminal conduct.
The states have their own
criminal law to enforce.
So technically, someone
could be prosecuted let's say
by the Commonwealth of Virginia
for a drug conspiracy and convicted.
And then could be prosecuted
again by the federal government
or another state for the
same criminal activity
and be convicted or acquitted
and the double jeopardy
clause would not be violated.
The second thing about double jeopardy is
that it only protects
you from being prosecuted
a second time by the same
sovereign for the same crime.
It doesn't protect you
from being prosecuted
for a different crime.
Suppose the State of California
prosecutes a defendant
for murder and the defendant is acquitted,
the State of California could then bring
a second prosecution for a
kidnapping of the same victim
that actually occurred before the murder.
And because that's a different crime,
the double jeopardy clause doesn't bar
a separate prosecution.
- [Kim] And so there's also a clause here
that says an individual
shall not be compelled
in any criminal case to be
a witness against himself.
So, this is what we call
taking the fifth, right?
What does that mean?
- [Dripps] So, the fifth
amendment privilege is a privilege
that can be asserted by
anyone who is called to answer
by agents of the government
and to claim the privilege
it has to be the case that
the witness is being compelled
to speak will suffer adverse consequences
if she doesn't answer the
questions the government officers
want her to answer.
Those answers have to tend
to incriminate the witness
and those answers have to be testimonial,
that is to say they have to say
in some way they constitute witnessing.
- [Saltzburg] Good lawyers,
good lawyers will generally
advise their clients to take the fifth.
That is, claim their privilege
against self-incrimination
almost any time that the government
is seriously investigating them.
And the reason is people's
memories are often bad,
that when people are asked
question they may believe
that something happened in a certain way
but they haven't gone back to review it.
And when people make
mistakes, simple mistakes,
that are made in response to a question
may look like people deliberately lied.
They may make someone look
like they were attempting
to deceive investigators.
And therefore, when in doubt,
individuals who are being
investigated have good reason to invoke
their privilege against
self-incrimination.
- [Dripps] Historically,
there were two things
that the fifth amendment privilege
was really supposed to prevent.
One was that while the
English system relied
on grand juries and petty
juries and cross examination,
confrontational trials,
the European system
of the Founding era
even as late as the end
of the 18th century still
relied on juridical torture.
So, if there was a lot
of preliminary proof,
if it's super probable
cause against a suspect
in say France or Germany,
the judges will authorize
to torture the target into confessing.
They didn't want to adopt
this inquisitorial practices
of continental Europe.
And the other great abuse
behind the privilege
was the Court of Star Chamber's
use of the oath ex officio
which was witnesses were
called before the Star Chamber
without knowing what the
investigation was about,
whether they were a target,
what they were suspected of doing,
and the first thing that happened
was they were obliged to swear an oath.
And there was a famous
case involving a man
named John Lilburne who
refused to take the oath
and was torturously punished
by the Court of Star Chamber
for refusing to take that
oath they pilloried him
and they flogged him, and
his case was seen as kind of
an example of the kinds of
abuses that might be done
by asking questions subject to
oaths where the answer might
incriminate you or expose your to perjury,
or expose your soul to
eternal consequences.
So, those two things were behind
the privilege against self-incrimination.
The Founders didn't want either of those
to come back from the past
to haunt the new continent.
- [Kim] Say that I have committed a crime,
what might happen?
Are police or investigators required
to tell me about my right
not to self-incriminate?
- [Saltzburg] Starting 1966, in the case
that many people have now heard
of Miranda versus Arizona.
The United States Supreme Court held
that when a person is in custody,
that is generally has been arrested
and the investigators or prosecutors want
to question the suspect
they have to give a series
of warnings which are widely
known as the Miranda Warnings.
In short, they have to say to the suspect,
"You have the right to remain silent.
"Anything you say can and will be used
"against you in a court of law.
"You have the right to
have a lawyer present
"during any questioning, and
if you cannot afford a lawyer,
"one will be appointed for you."
- [Dripps] When the suspect is in custody,
they have to give the
famous Miranda Warning
that everybody knows from
movies and television
and so forth, and that's the one case
where the government is
required to be proactive.
In front of a congressional committee
or grand jury investigation,
or if you're just a witness
at a civil trial, and there's a question
that might expose you
to criminal liability
you have to claim the privilege.
You have to say, "I refuse
to answer that question
"on the grounds that
it may incriminate me."
When the suspect is under arrest
and the police wanna question him,
they have a different duty.
They have a duty to
proactively give him a warning
to make sure that he
understands his rights,
that he doesn't have to
say anything to the police,
that what he does say could
be admissible against him.
- [Kim] So, we've learned
that the fifth amendment
protects citizens from
possible abuses of power
by the government when an individual
is charged with a crime.
It requires a grand jury to determine
whether an individual should
be indicted for a crime.
Limits the number of times an individual
can be tried for the same crime.
Protects people from
self-incrimination and requires
that the government follow fair procedures
in prosecuting the law.
To learn more about the fifth amendment
visit the National Constitution Center's
interactive constitution
and Khan Academy's resources
on US government and politics.